bonjour bonjour
l'accueil est pour le moins originale
pour un local de la croix rouge
les jouets les peluches et les couleurs
sont ici les maîtres des lieux
le nouvel espace bébés par an est ouvert
à guyancourt depuis un an il reçoit des
familles en proie à des difficultés
sociales et économiques
les mamans et plupart du temps et non
pas de papa et c'est bien dommage vont
jouer avec leurs enfants et vont pouvoir
échanger avec d'autres mamans et les
enfants pourront s'y jouer avec d'autres
enfants est à voir comme ça les premiers
pas de la sociabilisation et leur
permettre de faciliter l'entrée dans la
scolarité ont un an près d'une
cinquantaine de familles ont bénéficié
des services de la croix rouge dans ce
nouvel espace en plus de conseils en
matière de nutrition infantile ou
d'hygiène les parents peuvent également
sous condition profiter d'une aide
matérielle ou vous avez l'ailé et petits
pots les vêtements et le matériel de
puériculture que nous offrons proposons
au moment qui en ont besoin
premier accueil du genre à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet espace
bébés par an est installé dans le
quartier des garennes à guyancourt à
proximité du centre social local on est
dans un quartier où il ya une mixité
sociale importante où on va rencontrer
ddd structure pavillonnaire mais on va
rencontrer aussi plusieurs bailleurs
sociaux avec des gens qui ont des
difficultés différentes les uns des
autres
et cet accueil bébés parents complète
l'attend
la réponse à la tempe de ces familles le
nouvel espace est ouvert tous les mardis
et jeudis matin les horaires pourraient
être élargies en fonction de la demande